that was a good [__] goal let's
[__] go
let's go
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
sunshine I think people are incredibly
naive to what I'm up to I think the Best
Buy in all of the friends were the
access tokens
Gary you see my paddle so I had this
before I knew I was coming here so I it
was a collector's item and I ripped it
open I had to play with it yeah
want to play a couple points
in this
and this 10 9.
[Music]
thank you God he got me this time
I know you guys wanted me to lose how
are you good to see you good to see you
thanks for coming we got this Tyler he
stinks
I just was out here for 90 minutes
playing pickleball with garyvee himself
for me somebody who loves sports I
couldn't even dream I couldn't even
think that this would ever happen to me
and here I am had a really great
experience one-on-one with garyvee Dee
friends family you are the best I am so
thrilled that I got involved and I am a
forever be friend
morning morning morning
how you doing good to see you again you
too things are good great to see you
so well
yo what's up brother
[Music]
thanks for stopping by so these guys uh
own a special be friends nft that gets
us to have brunch together and I just
wanted to surprise them with some fun
people the one thing that you you have
because like you've just proven it in so
many different fields you can take it
your armor plate and I'm not there yet
that that comes from a place of deep
deep compassion and empathy I genuinely
do not believe when someone's trying to
hurt me that it's a reflection of me I
just can't see it that way I don't think
it means anything about my self-worth to
remain as unaffected and to continue
well you know what that requires to not
cure the accolades either I think about
that a lot if you're obsessed with the
cheering You're vulnerable to The
Bullying wow
I'm super amazing all right guys talk to
you soon see ya
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
good to see you this is generally my
favorite thing to do the second I walked
in I'm like this is gonna be the best
like I love this so much don't you think
that IP attention in general is going to
be even more valuable in the future yes
my whole thesis has been technology is
going to commoditize everything except
the ability to storytell and grab
attention do you know how bad I was at
search when Yahoo came out like I didn't
even know what to do in 1995 I was like
wine enter
yeah you now understand it but we
weren't trained to use search do you
understand the dumb [__] we're putting
in the chat gbt today compared to eight
years from now what we're gonna be
putting in there that's why I get mad
when people like this is the worst I'm
like it's going to teach critical
thinking yeah
[Music]
how is everybody
good good there he is decided to bring a
special guest what's up dude
[Music]
it's like an investment in like
someone's like pizza shop or buying an
nft project or like you know buying a
stock is not identity when you say I go
into it you do not you know what I mean
they're like I get complacency what I
what I do that's the problem yeah like I
have the know how to say okay in 13
months I'm out of here I'm going into
something 100 have you contemplated not
coming up with it by 13 months so I
think one of the things I fear
completely is when people create
artificial timelines you start making
bad decisions here's the Alternatives
I'm going to subjectively anxiously make
a complete call on what I'm gonna do in
13 months or I can extend it for it to
naturally happen the way it always works
mentally in my head say I can afford to
take a one or two Year Dad Gap year and
actually go fully in I think the
artificial time frame is the poison
killer and so I would highly recommend
debating that Ryan thank you so much for
coming brother
let's use that song in this in this Vlog
yeah
[Music]
yo make sure you do your 25 push-ups
today and because I'm passionate of like
living what I speak I'm gonna bang out
mine right now here we go
[Music]
let's go
down
[Music]
how are you a very very very very
special episode of the garyvee audio
experience for everyone who's listening
to the podcast I really do see all my
tweets so please hit me up on Twitter
would love to get your perspectives what
you like what's helped you I know it's
working but today's episode is really
kind of a meta thing Jonathan why don't
you tell the Vayner Nation who you are
what you do but then tell us why you're
here my name is John Tory co-founder and
director of marketing at Searchlight in
2019 I was a product manager but I felt
very stuck and I was listening to one of
your podcasts and you said garage
sailing is one of the best start right
now business experiences that you can go
get so I took it around with it that
turned into sports card trading then
that led me to writing for 1 37 p.m but
in between there we started a little
company called Searchlight Advertising
so thank you
because your advice just taking it
running with it really helped there are
six people listening to me for nine
years who now that you just said it and
it's not me saying it have decided to do
it it's without people like you it's not
fulfilling I know what I'm putting out I
know what happens if people do it I just
know that 99 of people that listen to me
don't do it I think for everyone you
could tell why I wanted this man on I
feel like this episode is gonna get 16
of you off your butt my man I'm so
grateful listen too many people just
don't believe it they don't think them
it's just not true love you see ya bye
everyone hope you enjoyed this episode
yeah I'm a little bit worried like
honestly it's funny you say that even
though I do feel confident I had a
feeling that it was going to put in work
this time I might be in trouble but I'm
a defensive Savant brother how are you
good it's good to see you
correct
oh that was a good [__] goal
s
let's [__] go
let's go
bam well thank you sir the ass whooping
well and some real [__] like you played
well oh thank you thank you the first
the first goal they had to have you
nervous a little Icebreaker Off the Wall
[__] petrified I was I mean 4-2
everyone [__] doubted me in here
which is why I had to get serious when I
was down four or two I was nervous face
I was on 4-2 in game one
no it was scale ladies
good to see you you guys well yeah how
are you need anything for me no not
right now so far so good eventually yeah
[Music]
oh my God
let's see how was your day amazing you
need anything
feeling good feeling great
let me know if you need me I was nervous
4-2 and then I [__] like just like
really [__] decided [__] got in my
own [__] head and said I'm not
[__] losing here all right I gotta
get the [__] out of here fast
[Music]
[Applause]